good afternoon it is a real pleasure to
speak to you today
at the global teacher prize ceremony
broadcast from london
in the united kingdom as the global
teacher prize ceremony now
moves around the world making its
reputation
live up to its name as a true global
celebration of teachers
it's an honor that london has been
chosen as the first of the new host
cities
although i'm speaking to you in
difficult and sometimes heartbreaking
circumstances it's right that we take
time to recognize
the enormous contribution and sacrifice
of the world's teachers during this
pandemic
teachers like you jamie frost
congratulations on winning the global
teacher prize
coved hero award
your creativity and ingenuity has given
hope
and support to millions of children
throughout the world
it's been incredible to see how teachers
have adapted
to home learning and use technology to
continue with lessons
throughout the pandemic
you don't just represent the heroic
teachers in the united kingdom
but also across the whole world
thank you once again to all the world's
teachers